Daniel veishea bello engineering and
applied science I know this is a cliche
sometimes but the well-rounded education
that you get a Columbia really does make
a difference not only as an engineer but
also for solving life's problems it
taught me a way of thinking that i have
used throughout my life my daughter she
came here for her graduate studies one
day i get a text message from my
daughter of a picture of her walking up
the cables of the manhattan bridge the
funny part of that story is that the
person who got her involved was a
professor of mine professor Randy testa
and when my daughter was a student here
I asked professor Randy testa to look
out for my daughter well so much for
looking out for my daughter so when I
got my master's degree I did not
participate in commencement when my
daughter graduated with her master's
degree from Columbia I was president of
the Alumni Association and I also got to
give my daughter her class pin and she
was the only one among all the graduates
I got a hug and tier on class day and we
both wore our masters regalia for the
very first time together and it was just
a very special moment for me when I come
back to campus when I'm sitting in this
laboratory as an example I always feel
like I'm coming home and it's a very
nostalgic feeling and I try to share
that with other alums so that they then
to become engaged you have the ability
to make a product make a difference in
the process not only between the alums
in the school but also in the lives of
faculty and students
and I've made lasting friendships with
all of them congratulations very much I
participated very selfishly because I
enjoyed it but to get a medal for
something that you enjoyed is the
ultimate combination and it just made me
extremely happy